[Music]
this is the story of how one man's dumb
idea created the worst tournament in
esports history
managed to piss off some of esports
biggest teams and
bankrupt his own company wonderland has
lived in
infamy as the worst event ever the fire
festival of gaming with missing
computers
confiscated passports and of course not
a cent
of prize money paid out shittiest
[ __ ] event
that has ever happened to the point
where people are literally grateful to
get out of the country
with their lives let alone their [ __ ]
prize money
if you thought that i buy power masters
or the shanghai major had problems
let me introduce you to the gaming
paradise
that was the worst tournament ever it
was insane
gaming paradise was the brainchild of
sasa bullock the ceo of a tournament
organizer called the gaming resorts
which
confusingly was not an actual resort
the event was supposed to hold dota and
cs go tournaments with a fifty thousand
dollar prize pool for each
in puerto ros slovenia a small town on
the country's adriatic
coast bullick was a software engineer
with no
event production experience so he turned
to petar markovic and his tournament
organizer company
gaming.rs to help turn his tournament
dream
into a reality gaming.rs organized a
tournament and handled all the
infrastructural concerns that means
stage
internet venue they are basically
responsible for making sure the show
happened the gaming resorts on the other
hand were the sponsor that means they
handled any of the financial concerns
for the event paying for the venue
paying the prize money
all of the cash flow gaming paradise was
billed as a three-day festival of and
i'm quoting here
live music killer beer and epic
gaming as teams flew into slovenia for
the cs go qualifier the gaming resort is
responsible for bussing players from the
airport to the venue
but the buses were late and the players
didn't actually arrive at the venue
until 3 00 in the morning
[Applause]
organization
[Music]
the next day games were supposed to be
held intense outside
but everything got delayed because of a
heavy storm
that blew through the town um
[Applause]
it was a literal act of god a sign from
the heavens that this tournament was
cursed and yet the real show was only
going to begin in a few months in late
august gaming rs went to the venue to
start setting everything up
there was one problem though there were
no pcs
according to markovic the gaming resorts
were responsible for getting the
computers from a gaming cafe in brussels
12 hours away but one of their drivers
went completely m.i.a
left with only one truck the remaining
driver asked the gaming resorts which
was more important
the pcs or the monitors they chose the
monitors
yeah i don't know why either what
actually happened
computers never came so they
changed their minds they got some other
pcs that
weren't really for gaming those pcs
didn't have graphic cards
and those arrived a bit late so they
then try to manage to get some graphic
cards so we can run the tournament
without the pcs from brussels the only
computers they had left were 20 old
workstations with out-of-date cpus and
graphics cards
but don't worry they managed to upgrade
the computers thanks to shady bitcoin
miners from slovenia
the only problem was they still weren't
powerful enough to run the games
properly
all of this less than one week before
the tournament was set to begin
the cs go tournament was supposed to
start on september 6th
but of course it got delayed when the
games actually did start the stream
quality was a
subpar to say the least see and all the
scramble to set everything up and get
graphics cards
no one tested the stream and while they
were promised decent internet
what they got was garbage on day two
gaming paradise announced the dota 2
tournament
was just cancelled they said that
because they were having so much trouble
running cs go it was best for them to
just focus on
fixing all of that first but instead of
fixing the issues
things actually got much much worse
what's the worst thing you can imagine
happening to you at an esports event
losing not getting paid try getting your
passport
confiscated by the police uh first bad
thing that happened today
one of our staff members from gaming rs
approached me and told me that
he can't get his passport from the
reception of the
whole marina where this is when you and
where this venue is and the hotel and
everything
we went to to the reception and ask
what's going on and they told us that uh
the venue and the marina didn't uh
didn't get paid enough to give us
the personal ids and to get
back to the rooms this was a huge
problem the gaming resorts didn't
actually pay for the hotel or the marina
that were hosting the tournament
and while they were trying to figure out
what the problem was the police decided
to just take everyone's passport so they
couldn't go anywhere now the players
were trapped
no way out of slovenia at a tournament
with no food no computers and
increasingly
no hope three of the teams were supposed
to be playing in the esl esea
invitational tournament in dubai just a
few days later
but of course everyone was stuck not
just the teams trying to escape to a
better tournament
other tournaments have messed up in the
past but
nothing has ever been this bad a couple
of missing computers and technical
delays is
nothing compared to being stranded in a
foreign country without your passport
to make matters worse representatives of
the venue also pissed off that they
weren't paid
decided to lock all the production staff
out gamers.rs tried to save the event
negotiating with police to get passports
back and unlock the venue
but there was more bad news remember
sasebollik the gaming resort ceo
he showed up and told all the teams that
they weren't going to be paid the prize
money they were owed
in fact the tournament was cancelled
unless all the teams agreed
to being paid up to 90 days after the
tournament ended
and they all agreed so we called an
urgent meeting with all the players and
told them about the situation that's why
we got the whole delay thing today
and we also invited the ceo of
the gaming resorts so he talked with
them
and the final decision is to continue
the games and players will
sign a contract with exclusively the
gaming resorts
for that matter and after a few matches
were cut short due to time constraints
kinguin ended up winning the tournament
and walked away with a 90-day iou for 30
000 despite the promises from bullock no
prize money was
ever actually paid out the gaming
resorts filed for bankruptcy and bullock
disappeared he i remember he said
something about it he said like
this is by far the best tournament ever
and then he ended everything in like
hail satan or something he said
something like that it was so
weird and he was like signing papers
left and right
left and right about everyone is getting
money
but much more money and blah blah blah
like he just disappeared
he did however give the daily dot one
more quote for
everyone to remember him by it was my
first event he said
and i still did much better than anybody
around
bullock's inexperience turned his
dreamhack-esque fantasy into a
laughing stock gaming.rs was left to
clean up the mess
they helped teams get their players to
dubai for the invitational they helped
players get their passports back
they pretty much cleaned up everything
they possibly could have
their ceo even did a reddit ama where he
answered any question that he could
gaming paradise is without question the
worst plan
ever it had everything busted computers
seized passports a literal
act of god you couldn't write a more
perfect
disaster esports production has come a
long way in the last couple of years
so remember next time you're complaining
in twitch chat about how bad a
tournament seems to you
it could have been a lot worse it could
have been gaming paradise
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
you